so we can say toilet now
well according to tatler you can
according to me you can't i still think
it's a pretty horrid word and it's also
inaccurate as well because the toilet
historically was a person's makeup the
powdered wigs or you're there's going
back to the georgian times your your
white makeup that you would put on your
powder on your face
um hence toiletries bag go to toilette
the actual thing you do your business in
that's a lavatory so actually calling
the
the china thing in your bathroom uh a
toilet technically is wrong from my
point of view but tatler seem to think
it's okay um but that said i will use
the t word sometimes when i'm abroad
because people in other countries have
no idea what a laboratory is so uh i
would personally still like to call it a
lavatory but what is pleasing about this
list uh is that we can still be snobs uh
that has not gone out and actually do
make the key point that there is a
difference between there is a difference
between being intolerant and a snob and
snobs
can tolerate other things okay how do
you feel about cockapoos
uh yeah well they're not they're not the
dog of choice that i would go for but
they can be very cute for other people
uh but i wouldn't necessarily have one
my myself
okay so are they in or out now is
concerned can you be posh and have a
cockapoo
according to chaplain no they they are
they are something that you still can be
snobby about according to that there's
no there's no uh pets that you can't uh
be snobby about uh pets negroni's my
producer wants to know why a negroni is
just
so
no it's his favorite cocktail apparently
well it's sort of it's sort of going
through a resurgence like gin and tonics
did supposedly ten years ago and now
everything is gin this gin there are so
many different types of gin so negroni
seems to be this um
it was a cocktail that was started by an
italian
aristocrats
50 60 70 years ago and now is is sort of
the thing to to drink because it looks
very nice it's quite instagrammable uh
which is probably what's made it quite
naff
harry and megan we can't be rude about
them
uh well again according to handler uh
i'm sure a lot of us can raise an
eyebrow at some of their um behavior and
and choices uh but tatler have clearly
decided that uh we should maybe give
them a bit of a break uh isaac love
island
love island
uh no love island you can be snobby
about that's it's it's a terrible
program um that's fine
oh that's that's a bit harsh why do you
feel so strongly about it are you being
a bit snobby
well yes uh yes and i think it's it's
much better snobbery becomes dangerous
when people try and pretend that
strawberry doesn't exist but it does
exist whether it's sort of from a
perceived higher level looking down at a
perceived lower level or vice versa
inverted snobbery is is just as bad
or as prevalent as as sort of
traditional snobbery um but yeah love
island is is fairly vacuous television
a final thought before i let you go if
you no you're not really supposed to
have um a cockapoo
so-so on uh negroni's and um as far as
lavatories and toilets are concerned if
you use the wrong phrase of course if
you're talking to somebody who has the
right etiquette it doesn't really matter
does it
no of course and we will interact with
people who use the wrong terminology
every day and of course the classic
british thing to do is to say absolutely
nothing treat them with absolute respect
but inside in your head you think what